[Music]
if a disease breaks out anywhere in the
world the epidemic intelligence service
where E is is called in to investigate
the outbreak a lot of people refer to
EIS as the disease detectives because we
are the ones sent out during outbreak or
emergency response situations the elite
team works quickly to figure out who is
sick the origin of the infection and how
to stop it from spreading I'm Caitlin
Casa boom I'm a second year epidemic
intelligence service officer at the US
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention my first outbreak was an
impact outbreak in wildlife in Namibia
over 200 hippos and cape buffalo died
over a thousand people were exposed to
the carcasses we assisted Namibia with
control efforts in order to prevent
future infections today
kaylynn has been deployed here on st.
Croix in the US Virgin Islands in
September 2017 the islands were hit by
two major hurricanes in the aftermath
several people fell sick to a bacterial
disease called leptospirosis the first
time it was seen on the islands the
local health department needed backup so
they called in the disease detectives
leptospirosis or electro is a bacterial
disease spread through the urine of
infected animals if there's flooding or
rain human could have contact with water
that has been contaminated the symptoms
of lepto are flu-like illness but people
that get a very serious infection it can
be fatal
we have 14 people from CDC that are down
here for this as well as at least 25
local volunteers we're gonna go back to
the block that we were in yesterday um
yes thought it'd be pretty quick once
the team has their map assignments the
detective work begins we start going
door-to-door with a primary goal of
educating people on the disease we asked
them if they would be willing to take a
survey we take a small amount of blood
so that we can test and see if they've
been exposed to lepto
the lab takes the specimen they'll
centrifuge or spin down the specimens
and then they'll store those for
freezing to be eventually mailed back to
CDC in Atlanta for the testing what
we're really hoping is that the
Department of Health can use that
information when paired with the survey
data to identify risk factors for
exposures
I have a training and animal diseases
and being able to apply that to help
humans is kind of the best of both
worlds
you're doing something that is actively
preventing people from getting sick with
really serious diseases being out there
and doing that and interacting with
people and you know making that
difference it's been a great experience
[Music]